on two three four five six seven eight
nine ten one two brilliant guys 1 2 3 4
5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 1 2 3 I switch on 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 1 2 3 4 1 2 is
green like 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 1 2 3 4
one two three four
one two three four
one two three four one two three four
lapel number two one two three four one
two three four five six lapel number two
one two three four lapel number three
one two three four one two one two one
two
good morning everyone thank you all for
coming today I want to set out the steps
we in government and you in business the
public sector and the voluntary sector
should take in order that we can make
sure that the United Kingdom goes from
strength to strength even in the
unlikely event that we do not reach a
negotiated deal with the European Union
I'm just back from Brussels after a
further round of negotiations with
Michel Barnier we're stepping up the
pace and the intensity of our
negotiations and I'm confident that a
good deal is within our sights that
remains our top priority it remains our
overriding priority so before I talk
about planning for no deal and the
technical notices that we're publishing
today I want to reaffirm what we expect
the negotiations to deliver a good deal
with our EU friends one that works in
our mutual interests and a deal that
recognizes our shared history and values
but also provides a strong and
sustainable foundation for our future
relationship
so yes winding down our membership of
the EU but maintaining our close trading
relationship building on our operational
security cooperation and sustaining the
networks of cooperation from research to
student exchanges which we prize on all
sides I'm still confident that getting a
good deal is by far the most likely
outcome
the vast majority roughly 80% of the
withdrawal agreement has now been agreed
and we're making further progress on
those outstanding separation issues and
of course those settled issues include
our agreement on citizens rights so that
3.5 million EU citizens living in the UK
and the 1 million Brits living in the EU
have their rights assured and can carry
on living as they do now now on the
basis that nothing is agreed until
everything is agreed we've agreed the
financial settlement and we've also
agreed the terms of an implementation
period to give businesses the clarity
and a sensible lead time to adjust to
the changes that brick
it will bring whilst also making sure
that people can feel confident that
there is some finality to the whole
process of leaving the EU on Tuesday I
met with Michel Barnier in Brussels for
the third time since my appointment we
made progress on those outstanding
separation issues we continued our focus
on the incredibly important issue around
Northern Ireland and I explained further
the UK proposals on our future
relationship based on the white paper
that we published in July addressing our
future economic partnership as well as
the security cooperation that we want to
continue to protect all of our citizens
I'm pleased we've now agreed with the EU
to continuous negotiations as I've been
arguing for to energize the final phase
of the debate of the diplomacy and to
reach a deal that is in both sides
interests if as I expect the EU responds
with the same level of ambition and
pragmatism we will strike a strong deal
that benefits both sides
and at the same time naturally we've got
to consider the alternative possibility
the EU doesn't match our ambition and
pragmatism but we do not reach a deal
but let me be clear about this it is not
what we want and it's not what we expect
but we must be ready we have a duty as a
responsible government to plan for every
eventuality and to do this we need to
have a sensible responsible and
realistic conversation about what a No
Deal situation really means in practice
for citizens for businesses for public
sector bodies for NGOs and we also need
to take some steps now so we can avoid
and mitigate those risks that arise so
today we're publishing the first 25 in a
series of technical notices they're
designed to inform people and businesses
in the UK about what they may need to do
if we don't reach a deal with the EU the
notices are practical and proportionate
they prioritize stability for our people
our businesses and for our country
they're part of a common-sense approach
to planning for a No Deal brexit and
they underline our resolve whatever the
outcome of the negotiations to chart our
own course in collaboration with friends
abroad to deliver on brexit in a way
that serves the best interest of the
British people in the notices themselves
we set out clear steps that public
institutions companies and people should
take or consider taking in order to
avoid or mitigate or manage the risk of
any potential short-term disruption the
overarching aim of the notices is to
facilitate the smooth continued
functioning of business transport
infrastructure research aid programs and
funding streams that have previously
come from the EU in some cases it will
mean taking unilateral action to
maintain as much continuity as possible
at least in the short term in the event
of no deal and irrespective of whether
the EU reciprocates in practice let me
just give you one example of what I mean
by that the batch testing of medicines
at them
at the moment they only need to go
through one set of checks either here in
the UK or in the EU in order that they
are deemed safe to be used by patients
and that's by virtue of our
participation in the European regulatory
network now in a no deal scenario the UK
won't be a participant in the European
regulatory network that supports this
process but we don't want delays or
disruption to supplies from the EU so we
propose accepting the testing and safety
approvals of existing medicines if
they've been carried out by a member
state regulator and that's just one
illustration of what we would do in a
pragmatic way unilaterally if we
required to do so it's a sensible
approach for two reasons first it
simplifies the planning for those
businesses that are exporting from the
EU by avoiding the need at short notice
to adapt to new regulations secondly it
minimizes any potential disruption for
UK businesses or consumers on that
particular source of supply in this case
medicines from the EU now of course
given that we start from a position of
common rules we would also hope and I
think expect in good faith between close
partners that the EU would recognize
medicines from this country with our
regulatory approval but in the No Deal
scenario we can't guarantee it now more
generally whilst we may choose to take
this approach to achieve continuity and
stability in the short term let's be
clear about it we'll be outside the EU
we will be free to diverge but we would
only do so when we are ready on our
terms
in the UK national interest when it's
right for the British people
the reason I took the job of brexit
secretary is because at this crucial
moment in our history I want to see the
UK leave the EU in the best possible way
preferably with a deal but prepared on
any eventualities to manage the risks
and grasp the opportunities of life
outside the EU when I was appointed the
prime minister and I discussed the
importance of stepping up our No Deal
preparations and with seven months to go
until we leave we need to pick up that
work so that our plans are properly in
place in time and that will enable us to
build on the substantial preparations
that have already been made over the
last two years and I'd like if I may
just to set a few of them out first of
all working with Parliament we've put in
place the legislation we need that
includes the EU withdrawal Act that
enables us to take that control of our
laws whilst guaranteeing that our exit
from the EU is smooth and orderly we've
passed legislation that the UK that's to
make sure that the UK has the legal
powers it needs to support British
truckers to continue operating
internationally and we've enacted the
nuclear safeguards Act to provide a new
regime for safeguarding our nuclear
materials which will come into effect
when we leave your atom now over the
coming months we're going to continue to
put those legislating blocks in place so
that's the first thing the legislative
framework the second thing we're doing
is recruiting the extra staff we need
cross government making sure departments
have the right people with the right
skills to deliver a smooth transition
there are more than 7,000 people working
on brexit there is funding for an extra
9000 staff to be recruited into the
civil service enabling us to accelerate
government preparations as and when we
need to and also just as important as
that in relation to frontline services
such as the UK's border force we are
currently recruiting an extra 300 staff
in time for our exit with plans in the
pipeline to recruit 1,000 more staff so
they're ready to deal with any increase
in work so the legislation and the staff
thirdly we're bolstering our
institutional capacity for example our
competitions and Markets Authority will
take on an additional role as the UK
state aid regulator
while the Information Commissioner's
Office will support businesses with the
new data arrangements that we would put
in place after exit fourth beyond those
domestic preparations we're making sure
we're in the best position to continue
key international agreements that are
currently linked to our membership of
the EU for instance we signed a new
nuclear safeguarding agreement with the
International Atomic Energy Agency and
we struck a bilateral nuclear
cooperation agreement with the US v all
of this requires money which is why the
Chancellor committed a further three
billion pounds in the budget on top of
the 700 million already allocated for
planning and preparations so our laws
will be on the statute book the staff
will be in place the teams will be in
post and our institutions will be ready
for brexit Deal or No Deal
so today's technical notices take this
work forward to the next stage this is
the first batch in a series and we'll be
publishing more technical notices over
the coming weeks the ones out today will
explain how the UK would mitigate the
consequences of a No Deal scenario in a
range of ways so for instance supporting
businesses at the border the technical
notice and title trading with the EU if
there's no deal published today sets out
how we would ensure that on day one
there will be a functioning customs VAT
and exercise system giving advice to
businesses on how they will need to make
import and customs declarations register
for a UK economic operator registration
and identification number or make safety
declarations on goods being moved
between the EU from the EU to the UK
next the technical notes on workplace
rights explains the steps we are taking
to transfer all EU legislation into UK
law in time for exit so workers will
continue to be entitled to the rights
they have now such as flexible working
or parental leave many areas we already
go much further than the EU other
technical notices today published today
will address health care including
ensuring blood products are safe if we
leave the
without a deal and making sure that we
can continue to import blood supplies
from the EU even though in truth we are
relatively self-sufficient in this
regard and when it comes to scientific
research incorporation we're acting to
protect UK institutions and businesses
so we set out how we will underwrite all
successful horizon 2020 bids from UK
organisations in the No Deal scenario to
make sure that the UK retains its status
as a global leader in scientific
research now amidst all the technical
detail we understand that real
livelihoods are at stake it so for
example we're making sure our farmers
get the funds they've applied for with
the Treasury guaranteeing applications
made through the --use Common
Agricultural Policy up until 2020 and
yes British higher education
institutions should carry on bidding for
funding through Erasmus plus because as
we set out today the government will
underwrite successful bids until the end
of 2020 helping young people from this
country to continue to enjoy the
educational opportunities and the rich
tapestry of culture life right across
Europe so - for our trailblazing NGOs
fighting global poverty we've guaranteed
their funding from successful bids from
the European Civil Protection and
humanitarian aid operations so these
technical notices and the ones that will
follow shortly are a sensible measured
and proportionate approach to minimizing
the impact of No Deal on British firms
citizens charities and public bodies
they will provide information and
guidance and after some of the
misinformation that's been put about
lately some reassurance take just one
example of that the suggestion that a No
Deal brexit could spark a sandwich
famine in the UK or that we've asked the
army to deliver food supplies in reality
our food and drink supply is diverse in
2016
Deford statistics show the UK supplied
half of the food that we consume here at
home 30 percent did come from the EU 20
percent from the rest of the world who
is credibly suggesting a node
scenario that the EU would not want to
continue to sell food to UK consumers in
any event we've set out practical
measures to mitigate any risk of
disruption to supply through the
recognition of EU food standards our
pursuit of equivalents the Arrangements
on food regulation with the EU and
indeed with non EU countries and through
our support for our farmers at home
terms of the financial funding streams
so let me assure you that contrary to
one of the wilder claims you will still
be able to enjoy a BLT after brexit and
there are no plans to deploy the army to
maintain food supplants I think it's
also worth saying that most of the
worst-case scenarios being bandied
around implied that the EU would resist
all in any mutual cooperation with the
UK in reality I find it very difficult
to imagine that our EU partners would
not want to cooperate with us even in
that scenario in key areas like this
given the obvious mutual benefits
involved at the same time in the
unlikely and I think regrettable event
of no deal a balanced appraisal should
recognize that there would also be some
countervailing opportunities the
immediate recovery our full legend
regulatory control including over
immigration policy the unfettered
ability to lower tariffs to bring into
effect nude free trade deals that we
negotiate straight away and mindful of
our strict legal obligations a swifter
end to our financial contributions to
the EU so while we're striving for the
best outcome and a good deal from these
negotiations we stand ready to live a
brexit for the British people if there
is no deal by managing and mitigating
the risks by rising to the challenges
and by seizing the opportunities that
lie ahead now I think in reality many of
the no dual challenges will affect the
EU in similar or the same ways for our
part if the negotiations fail we would
continue to pay it as a responsible
European neighbor partner and Ally and
that would extend to the necessary
engagement with our EU friends when it
comes to No Deal planning
and I think they're already some
positive examples of this taking place
you take the dialogue that is already
ongoing between the Bank of England in
the European Central Bank it's a
sensible illustration of EU institutions
working with British ones to manage
shared risks for the good of everyone
the technical working group that was set
up in April will facilitate discussion
of risk management in financial services
to provide further confidence in the
financial services industry as we leave
the EU there are other areas where such
engagement needs to take place whether
between the UK and the EU on data
protection or between the UK and the EU
member states for example between Port
Authorities that's the responsible thing
for us to do on all sides we're raising
this issue with the EU to impress upon
them our joint responsibility to work
together to minimize any harm to UK and
European citizens and businesses those
lives those livelihoods on both sides
should be put ahead of any narrow
political interests equally that I hope
that such engagement on No Deal
necessaries it now is will be rendered
redundant by the successful outcome from
our negotiations and I'll be returning
to Brussels next week with that in mind
even as we continue to work on our No
Deal planning so my message to all of
you today is a pragmatic one please take
note of the practical information that
we're providing please do stay engaged
with us on the detail in the coming
months and weeks and review your own
contingency plans that way as we prepare
for our departure from the EU and as we
strain every sinew to deliver a new deep
and special partnership with our
European friends we will be ready in
case those efforts are not matched both
to manage down the risks but also to
grasp the opportunities that brexit will
present and in doing that I'm confident
that this country's best days lie ahead
thank you all very much
[Applause]
I'm very happy to take some questions
can I ask for one each and I'm going to
start with the journalist beth rigby
says levels are fine but look the truth
is as I said I've been out in Brussels
this week talking to Michelle bond they
will be back next week we're having an
extended negotiation next week I've been
very keen to pick up the pace of the
negotiations so we are absolutely
committed to this and we're making
progress all the time there are
certainly some outstanding issues but
we're making progress and I'm confident
that a good deal is within our sights
equally we have to prepare for the
possibility at least that the talks
don't reach the conclusion that we want
and I think what you're seeing today is
not the start of our no deal planning
but the continuation because it needs to
become more engaged with the public
because of the stakeholders that need to
be in receipt of guidance and advice and
what we've got is a sensible balanced
approach which looks at the risk but I
hope puts them in some kind of context
and demonstrates that we can avoid
mitigate or manage them at the same time
as making a success of brexit in the
broader sense that I described in my
opening speech Jean Pienaar BBC mr. Robb
do you accept that our No Deal brexit
would leave the country worse off and
not better off and the only question is
by how much and if I may as a brexit ear
and a lever you're asking Brussels to to
back off from red lines and if there's
no deal to cooperate in the way that
that you want
did you always envisage that so much of
your brexit plan would rely on wishful
thinking so firstly in relation to the
negotiations
I'm absolutely clear that the UK we
better off outside of the EU in any
scenario of the long term but I
recognize the risks of the short term
and these technical note is about taking
a balanced sober assessment of that and
working out the practical ways to make
it work in relation to the negotiations
I always thought this would be
challenging to go station because you've
got two sides but as I said in Brussels
and I confirm now we're going into this
with energy and ambition you can see
that in the white paper when showing the
flexibility and the compromises that
need to be made and if that's matched on
the EU side and I've got every reason to
believe it can and should be then we'll
get a deal Libby Libby via ITV News um
Secretary of State bricks it was sold to
businesses in Britain or something that
would liberate them make their job
easier but looking at these papers
they're effectively a red tape bonanza
that imposed all sorts of restrictions
on businesses what would you say to
business about the prospect of a No Deal
are they really going to be able to
thrive in that environment and secondly
haven't you actually left all British
citizens living in the EU in the lurch
because this scenario suggests they
might not even be able to access their
bank accounts their pensions wouldn't in
fact be paid when terms of businesses of
course and the majority of businesses
don't export to the EU but for those
that do and we want to see more
businesses exporting not just of EU but
to the growth opportunities around the
world from Asia to Latin America it's of
course in relation to those in the
current trading links with the EU
there'll be some extra regulatory
changes that they'll need to be advised
of the sensible thing to do is to give
practical advice and work with them to
make that a success but of course
outside of the EU there'll be all sorts
of other opportunities I get that but
the what the point I'm making is yes
we'll need to make sure as we trade with
the EU in the unlikely event you ala T
that there's no deal scenario that we
give practical advice in the same ways
businesses exporting to other countries
where we we don't have a free-trade
arrangement but there are also
opportunities whether it's around
regular to control the growth
from signing free trade deals with the
Asian markets or the Latin American ones
and on citizens will we be working very
carefully to with the EU and we've had
success in terms of withdrawal agreement
about securing the rights of British
nationals over on the continent an EU
nationals here and if we leave with no
deal we were going to make sure that we
provide as much reassurance as much
practical support to British expats that
broaden if you look at the technical
notice there's a series of information
and guidance about how we will do that
I've given you three well in terms of
contractual arrangements overseas that
will then change because we're not
considered strictly an EU Member State
you're right that there'll be a change
what we'll do in a no deal scenarios
work in good faith and the spirit of
cooperation with our EU friends and of
course those challenges will be there on
the other side as well so I would think
that was a practical issue that we ought
to be able to resolve Francis Elliot
from The Times sorry why when do you
commit to publishing all 84 technical
notices and isn't your message to land
traders across the Northern Irish border
RC Irish government is that really fair
and finally sorry your message to people
trading over the Northern Irish border
seems to be ask the Irish government is
that really fair and and thirdly um to
whom do you want to talk to whom on the
European side should be more responsible
in in its having the the European
Commission aren't mandated to discuss No
Deal planning so who should be
responsible you talking about the
commissioner or wait in terms of the
technical notices we're publishing 25
today that's roughly broadly more or
less a third of the total number and
we'll do them in a series and I would
expect them to be out over the coming
weeks and certainly by the end of
September
and immolation knows now businesses I'm
that's not the advice we're giving and
if you look at the technical notices I
think it's very clear we're trying to
give practical advice reassurance and of
course we'll keep talking in the event
reality of no deal with not just the EU
but with member states so what we're
trying to do is make sure people have
the information they need the lead time
they need and some guidance about the
practical way through some of the
difficulties in the unlikely event a
leti that we don't get a deal hairy from
the Sun thank you restate you admitting
the technical notices here that the fate
of banks British firms and British
pensioners relies on a reciprocal deal
from the EU what happens if you don't
get it and secondly aren't you just
admitting that in reality there is no
such thing as no deal because you're no
deal scenario planning is to forge a
deal with Brussels it doesn't make any
sense
that's not quite right because of course
some of the arrangements we might make
wouldn't necessary legal arrangements or
they may be with Member States or they
could be with regions of a particular
country or their institutions directly
and I think there is good reason to
think that even in a no deal scenario
there would be good faith and enough
Corp cooperation on both sides why
because well I mean if you look at the
example of pensioners which you give the
it's hardly in the interest of southern
Spain to do harm to the UK pensioners
out there and what you would expect and
I'm confident that we would see even in
the unlikely outcome of no deal is
actually cooler heads prevail and the
kind of practical cooperation to make
sure that contractual issues where their
pensions are otherwise uh navigated
through otherwise in any event you would
fall back on the generals of
international or including private
international law
I but I don't think realistically you're
suggesting I'm not sure you're even
suggesting the EU would sell out theirs
in order to gain some sort of indict
advantage over there over the UK I don't
think that attributing those kind of
intentions to the EU is either right or
we come to pass Chris Hope tell off
Chris Hope Telegraph Dominic two quick
questions why not warn consumers and
firms in the European Union about the
risks of a no deal to them why all these
warnings facing Britons and you
mentioned the safety of the BLT sandwich
which we all applaud these documents are
aimed mainly at companies what can
Britons at home do to prepare for No
Deal should this sit tight and hope I
don't think there's a huge amount for
the vast majority of consumers in this
country there's not going to be much
change at all if it's notable but the
issue is around businesses whether
they're exported particularly the ones
that are exporting in relation to
businesses importing or consumers things
like the approach to batch testing will
allow a seamless approach and that's
something within our control and in
relation to the EU no dual planning I've
raised this with Michel Barnier
we have got some good illustrations and
I mentioned them in my speech where the
EU institutions in the UK are working
together we probably need to see a bit
more of that but look I'm focused on the
negotiations we had a good week this
week and I'm looking forward to making
more progress next week I'm going to go
on and take is there any European
journalists look like a task question oh
no Rob not quite not quite gentlemen
there so I don't know your name yes on
the Irish border in the the paper on on
trade you talk about engagement on
arrangements for trade across the land
border are you in visiting here that
there would be a special arrangement for
the fur trade across the land border and
the trade between Ireland and the rest
of the UK would operate essentially the
way that it would with any other human
restate and secondly is it your view
that the Belfast agreement obliges the
governments of the UK and Ireland to
reach such a special arrangement well
look the technical notice set out the
practical information that we think the
ordinary and businesses should look at I
think we're saying very loud and clear
that we will not allow anything to
disrupt the terms of the Belfast
agreement and that we wouldn't return to
any form of hard border at the border
and that's a clear commitment and we've
got no intention of relenting from it
well I'm not quite sure that would look
like so I'm not going to hypothetically
the rule it in or out is there anyone
else from the European press corps
gentlemen err I Cal bear from the moon
from France are in those papers two
years late you know for instance you you
take medicines testing of medicines a
firm like Astra Zeneca is already
starting duplicating the testing
facilities in Sweden and here because
well those papers were not published
there was no reinsurance same thing for
you know EU citizens it's a big gap here
isn't it just coming way too late to
hope good face on the other side I think
actually if you look at the
pharmaceutical companies since the
referendum there's been a number of
examples of further investment put into
the UK so I don't think the position is
quite as dire as you suggested but let's
also bear in mind that in relation to
the maintaining a supply of say six
weeks worth of medicines in which is one
of the piece of advice that we've put
out today very mind the government
already works with pharmaceutical
companies to ensure we've got three
months worth of buffer stock for over
200 medicines through the emergency
medicines buffer stock scheme we're used
to having some disruption in relation to
supply whether it's because of issues on
the EU side not political ones but for
example industrial action the border
this may well be in the worst case
scenario different scale which is why we
taken these further practical measures
to make sure that we see continuity of
supply
I don't think it is at all and in fact
the timing of the technical notice is
building on the two years worth of work
that we've already done in which I hope
I set out clearly in my speech is
precisely in order to give those
affected the stakeholders affected the
lead time that they need I'm going to
take I take one more from gentleman here
so on the first one
look there's no suggestion of bringing
the military that that would be
necessary in the technical notices set
out the practical proposals that we've
we've got so you can see for yourself
what we are actually doing
I heard the comment from Amazon it was
at the chief achieving away day that we
organized to engage with businesses but
I only heard about in the press it
wasn't mentioned he didn't mention it to
me and I don't know anyone that was
there that heard that remark all I can
say is frankly it's not credible now I'm
going to take if I may some questions
from stakeholders so there are there any
stakeholders here from any of the
business groups or sexual groups would
like to ask a question is Marta
Krajewski energy okay when do you think
will move from planning for contingency
to actually triggering those contingency
planning and what would be the
government's communication around that I
couldn't stress more that a No Deal
scenario will have disastrous
consequences for the energy sector and
we very much hope that a deal with
Brussels will be achieved
well I share your ambition and in terms
of the technical notices as I said
they'll be a whole series following on
from this batch I suspect this batches
roughly a third in terms of the precise
point at which we no deal would become
clear and unavoidable fact that will
depend on the negotiations and indeed
the the relevant votes in Parliament
it's a CBI that's fine thank you John
Foster from the CBI um sexually state I
think the priority for CBI members
across the country would be securing the
original agreement to unlock the value
of that jobs first transition I think
businesses will welcome some of the
additional clarity that they have from
these notices but for many businesses
particularly smaller businesses there
will be questions still left unanswered
in your comments at the end you urge
business to continue to engage with
government quite practical question how
best should small businesses do that
well thank you for the question and the
the recognition of the the progress that
we've made I think for a lot of small
businesses they won't see any change
because of the proportion that wouldn't
export to the EU but as I said where you
want more to do so whether it's with the
EU or the other global markets and in
the technical notices we set out some of
the practical information that they'll
need the guidance they'll need and we'll
continue to engage with them directly
but also through the business groups
including CBI anyone else gentlemen
they're my Thompson from the
pharmaceutical industry secretary of
state first of all thank you very much
indeed for the announcements today
obviously the announcement on batch
tests releasing is really important to
our members and my members will be
delighted about that and that would be
an important step in securing medicines
for patients in the UK and like you I
very much hope now the EU will
reciprocate so that that same that same
step can be taken for European patients
also like you we hope that no deal won't
be the outcome and I just wonder whether
you can confirm that your DePalma will
continue to be pressing for a medicines
cooperation as the outcome of the
negotiations as outlined by the prime
minister in the mansion-house speech yes
well thank you for that and of course
what we're talking about with the batch
testing is the unilateral measures that
we would take in the unlikely event
reality of No Deal and if there was no
cooperation on the EU side but we would
be cooperating with the EU and of Cour
as a part of our negotiations as a whole
we are pursuing the associate membership
of the European Medicines Agency the
Prime Minister referred to and we will
keep that up and we as part of the
negotiations focus on that as well as
those other areas whether it's on trade
or on security where we want those
strong links to continue and indeed go
from strength to strength thank you very
much thank you thank you very much